for two weeks the gates at the airport
in kabul have been the portal to freedom
and safety for thousands of desperate
afghans and foreigners tonight they
became the gates to hell suicide
bombings have claimed numerous lives
including several u.s marines so-called
islamic state has claimed responsibility
and washington is warning that there
could be more attacks throughout the
night in kabul for their part the
taliban have condemned the blasts
could they have prevented the blasts
instead i'm brent goff in berlin this is
a special edition of the day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a hard day today as you know two
suicide bombers assessed to have been
isis fighters
detonated in the vicinity of the abbey
gate at hamad karzai international
airport and in the vicinity of the
barren hotel which is immediately
adjacent nobody expected such a
rapid and brutal
situation in kabul a barbaric a
terrorist attack a what looks like a
series of attacks this is an especially
despicable attack
in a very very tense situation this
incident underscores the volatility of
the situation on the ground in
afghanistan
[Music]
to our viewers on pbs in the united
states and to all of you around the
world welcome we begin the special
edition of the day with suspected
terrorist attacks near the airport in
kabul it is unclear how many people died
when the explosions ripped through
crowds of people earlier today the
pentagon has confirmed that several u.s
troops were killed it also announced
that evacuation flights despite the
attacks are still taking place
now
so-called islamic state we understand
has claimed responsibility for the blast
but just hours earlier u.s officials
warned of a specific incredible threat
at the airport by a terrorist group
associated with isis known as islamic
state coruscant or isis-k the taliban
they've condemned the attacks
here are the latest details that we have
one of the blasts was close to an
entrance of the airport known as abby
gates where crowds of civilians were
waiting another was a short distance
away near a hotel
thousands upon thousands of afghans and
foreign nationals have made their way to
the airport in the last two weeks in an
attempt to flee the country following
its takeover by the taliban
my first guest tonight is matt zeller a
former cia analyst who has served in
afghanistan as a u.s army captain he's
also the founder of no one left behind a
charity that helps afghans who worked
alongside the u.s military man it's good
to have you on
the program there's a lot to consider
after the events in kabul earlier today
despite these
apparent suicide bombings the pentagon
says that the evacuation flights
are continuing what's your reaction to
that
i
can't see how they could be i mean at
this point they must be only taking the
people who are still on the airport uh
my understanding is the gates have been
sealed shut literally welded shut
uh that there's ongoing destruction of
u.s equipment on the airfield right now
via controlled demolition which is
usually one of the last things that we
do before we we pull out
you know we've been running the numbers
here and by our estimation uh
we're probably going to end up leaving
behind around 175 000 people who needed
evacuation
well how do we have that number matt i
mean how did you calculate that number
because we've been asked many times how
do we know who's being left behind how
many people there are
sure
so our the organization that i represent
the association of wartime allies has
spent the better part of the last two
weeks with about 100 data scientists
working out of american university here
in washington dc
and the new york times they've scoured
the employment records of anybody who
worked for the us military the state
department us aid
anybody who has connected anyway with
nato or the international presence in
afghanistan for the last 20 years if
they could find an employment record
they've they've verified it and what
they've done is they've tried to do as
accurate of a count as they possibly
could
so we knew going into this that there
were about 88 000 afghan wartime allies
and their family members these were the
interpreters who had applied for the
special immigration visa they were
already on the books
but then
in the last month the president united
states announced that the evacuation was
expanded to include people who had
applied for something called a priority
one or priority two visa p1 or p2
the estimates there are just that their
estimates no one knows how many people
have actually availed themselves of the
program because they're brand new so
that's where going back to those
employment contracts was so important we
had to come up with an understanding of
how many people worked potentially for
the international forces over the last
20 years who could not at that point
avail themselves of the special
immigration visa program but now that
these newly created categories were on
the books
had a means of being able to get out and
so that's where this estimate comes from
the new york times reported this morning
that again we think the estimate total
of the needing evacuation at the time of
the evacuation began was around a
quarter million people around 250 000
the defense department has announced
that they've they've been able to move
about 105 000 people
why we're bumping that number up to
around 175 000
is
at the end of july congress changed the
rules of the special immigration visa
program
they changed it from requiring 24 months
of service to be eligible down to 12
months and we think that that change
alone
might have
basically allowed for an additional 25
000 people to then avail themselves of
the special immigration visa program
um they would not be on anybody's books
right now or anybody's you know tally
let me ask you
islamic state has claimed responsibility
for the attacks that we saw today
if that is true and if they were able to
get suicide bombers that close to the
airport
how concerned are you that maybe they
were able to get people with fake
documents through the vetting process
onto a plane that is taking would be
terrorists now to the west
let's be clear anybody who got on one of
those planes didn't get on with a weapon
or a bomb okay
we did this type of evacuation in 1975
out of saigon and in a week we moved 130
000 people all to the island of guam
which is a us territory
those 130 000 people then stayed on that
island while they were all processed and
one of the things that we learned was
1200 of those individuals were people
that we didn't want to enter the rest of
the united states in fact we didn't even
want them to be able to remain in guam
so we took them into custody they were
put into a confined space on the island
and then their deportation
uh was negotiated we found other
countries around the world that were
willing to accept these people and take
them in under the understanding that
they would not be allowed to travel to
the united states ever again in the
future that's what's going to happen
here
every single person who just got
evacuated from afghanistan have now been
you know they've been scattered to the
wind they're all over the world but
they're not just simply being dumped
onto american streets or to german
streets or you know any even qatari
streets they're all being held on
military bases
every single one of them is going to be
vetted every single one of them is going
to be we're going to make sure that they
are not a threat to anybody and i've got
and i've got to be honest yeah the
you know the the reason why you saw this
attack today and why people should be
concerned is because we trusted the
taliban with our security
a lot of people aren't talking about
this but if you if anyone who's been
following afghanistan they know for a
long time that nothing happens in kabul
without the permission of the haqqani
taliban the haqqani taliban are the ones
that look like the u.s boston operations
soldiers that have been on tv recently
they're also been the ones who took over
security control for the airport a mere
72 hours ago
one wonders given that they've had
historical ties to isis k and that
they've been the off the sort of the
affiliate of the taliban that have done
most of the joint operations with isis
in the past and that they're now in
charge of security at the airport i
really have to wonder
how much of this the taliban senior
leadership actually have been caught off
guard and how much of it some of them
might have already known about this that
again nothing in kabul ever happens
without the haqqanis uh it'd be very
interesting to see uh just how much the
taliban knew about this attack ahead of
time yeah that's a that's a very good
question some people saying this could
be the first failure about the taliban
to maintain security in afghanistan we
will see matt zeller former cie analyst
and veteran
from afghanistan matt it's good to have
you on the show we appreciate your time
and your insights tonight thank you
thanks for having me
[Music]
there have been several warnings of such
attacks over the past few days it's sad
news to hear that this has now taken
place we don't know all the details yet
but we know the terrorists targeted
people waiting at the airport for a
chance to leave the country
all they want
is to live safely and in freedom
and that's why
this is an especially despicable attack
in a very very tense situation
and my thoughts are with the victims and
their loved ones
with the german chancellor angela merkel
they're reacting to those attacks in
kabul german officials have now
confirmed that the country's evacuation
mission is over in afghanistan the final
plane left kabul earlier today more than
4 thousand afghans have also been
evacuated during the german airlift with
evacuees being taken first to uzbekistan
and then onwards from there germany's
defense minister said earlier today that
the attacks in kabul resulted in what is
being called an emergency departure by
german forces
all right let's go to our correspondent
nick connolly he is in tashkent in
uzbekistan good evening to you
nick you know you just heard our first
guest there
saying that it's over for the
evacuations getting people out of
afghanistan by air what are you hearing
there where you are i mean are they
expecting any more flights for example
well brent that military evacuation is
certainly over i think the decision has
been taken by the german authorities to
not put any more german service people
at risk for now but there has been talk
of further commercial flights and
negotiations as has been widely reported
between
german authorities and those taliban
representatives in qatar are continuing
uh towards that end and then obviously
there are the land borders afghanistan
has hundreds and hundreds of kilometers
of borders not only with pakistan the
place where most people have been
leaving for but also for uzbekistan
where i am here now it's about 600
kilometers from tashkent to the afghan
border tajikistan these are borders that
people have moved across in the past
indeed people fled from tajikistan to
afghanistan in the 90s when they had
their own civil war so this is the
expectation in the region now as these
weeks continue that these countries are
going to be preparing for an influx of
people even though they don't really
want to admit to it now and don't really
want to talk about it and have been
shielding these refugees in tashkent
from the press in the hope that somehow
this might go away but it doesn't seem
to be yeah it's not going away and the
people are not going to go away do we
know what happens to these people these
afghan nationals once they make it to
tashkent
so
the german government has rented an
entire terminal of the airport here in
tashkent and that's where the processing
takes part for the most part it seems
like the processing has been fairly
swift and people have been flown out on
commercial charter flights within a few
days
um as i said before we're not able to go
there neither the german side nor the
uzbek side in any hurry to let the press
in but we can tell people are being kept
under relatively acceptable conditions
but i think these are the lucky people
who managed to get on those lists i mean
four thousand people some people say
just under five it's a handful compared
to the thousands and thousands who ended
up working for german organizations uh
over those years in afghanistan and uh
lots of people now strambling to make
their way out across those land borders
i met people here in afghanistan rather
in tajikistan who are heading to
afghanistan to try and pick up their
relatives
on their own to try and get them out
whatever the price may be
our correspondent nick connolly
reporting tonight from tashkent nick as
always thank you
[Music]
when germany's evacuation mission began
it turned into a fierce blame game
opposition parties here in berlin blamed
the government for not evacuating german
and local staff sooner and for ignoring
warnings about the deteriorating
security situation but some in the
government blamed germany's intelligence
service for not anticipating how quickly
kabul would fall to the taliban dw news
asked german politicians here in berlin
a simple question what would they tell
those afghans who have been left behind
my message to the people in afghanistan
is we will not forget you we see you're
suffering we also see how the fight for
our common values continues
across german society from the army to
civil society but also here in
parliament from many different parties
there are a great many people who have
demanded that we rescue more people and
wish we'd been able to do so and i'm
sorry that that didn't happen
we must continue to assess what kind of
support is possible in the region in
particular decent accommodation must be
provided for refugees in afghanistan's
neighboring countries there needs to be
a close look at why other countries
managed to start flying out vulnerable
people earlier because there is a real
possibility that the government failed
here
these 16 years in afghanistan are the
darkest chapter in aggregate's tenure
this government bears responsibility for
the fact that people now have to be left
behind with decisive action things could
have turned out differently
well my next guest is roderick kizawetta
he's a member of parliament with angela
merkel's cdu party he sits on the
bundestags foreign affairs committee
he's also a former officer in the
bundesvaro the german armed forces it's
good to have you back here on the
program mr kizzavech you just heard
those rather damning criticisms
that we've been getting recent days the
evacuations started too late some say
some say they ended too early how do you
respond to that
well i thank you good evening mr goff i
ask for decency and humbleness to avoid
any lip service because those voices we
just have heard especially from the
green and the left
they abstained or voted against
the prolongation of our afghanistan
mandates in the last years
so it's
not a very fine sign of them
to argue now in this manner however we
need to be very careful our defense
minister asked already in april to
evacuate our
locals from the north
and
due to domestic reasons we prolong the
whole process too
long too much and therefore we have not
to blame our services our services
argued very early by by the end of last
year that they see that kabul will fall
without any violence latest by the end
of this year but due to the googles
of of some ministries
they didn't want to hear this process
and a last remark that the united states
evacuated
and and left the green zone
too early and without any coordination
with its partners and therefore they
created the mass anyway
the the u.s president has said that
the u.s cannot fight a civil war
for the afghans if the afghan people
themselves do not want to fight it
is there a lesson to be learned there
and and do you do you agree i mean do
you expect german soldiers to fight for
something that the afghan people
apparently are not willing to do now
well uh president biden um
earned or took the heritage of the
trump government and
he was wrong in his assessment
because we underestimated that the
afghan government
has had
no support from the afghan population
but we were aware about the
the corruption
all over the country second
the afghan security forces saw
already weeks before the evacuation that
the afghan technician the american
technicians left the the afghan security
forces alone and a third remark
i see that we left the afghan people we
left them alone in between is
al-qaeda and the taliban and a corrupt
afghan government so
it was a mistake in our assessment and
it is not a mistake of the african
people but mr kisabed how is it possible
i know this is being asked also in the
uk and the united states how is it
possible that your soldiers were there
in the country for two decades almost
two decades you were with the afghans
and yet it apparently they are as
strange and unknown to you now as they
were 20 years ago
i believe that the
program the whole process was wrong from
the outset it was a merely military
program and not a comprehensive one
regarding state building
regarding cohesion of the society
acknowledging that there are 45
different
tribes with 50 about 50 accents and
dialects and and languages so we
underestimated the separation the
partition of the whole country and there
was no comprehensive approach regarding
the cohesion of the country and
accepting as a kind of of cultural
awareness accepting their way to find
and to make decisions the
decision-making process of the afghan
society is not a democratic one as we
are used to we did not accept it uh we
we
just did not remark it so we were only
focused on the security forces and our
development policy was separate from
the build-up of the security forces so
it was a lack of comprehensiveness there
have been many voices who have named
this who have argued with that but it we
were not listened uh by our government
and we just prolonged the mandates
instead of evaluating the mandates and
this was a mistake not only by germany
by the whole nato and by the way it was
a loss of the whole nato system because
it was it was the first article five
operation ever of nato and it failed
yeah direct words there mr roderick
keyserveter
member of the cdu party and
the foreign affairs committee in the
german bundestag mr keys kuzafet as
always we appreciate your time and your
insights tonight thank you
thank you goodbye
[Music]
an uncertain new life is beginning here
in germany for the afghan refugees who
managed to escape their home country
while they're now safe most of their
family members and former colleagues are
still in afghanistan with essentially no
way to leave many are shocked that
germany has ended its evacuation mission
and many feel helpless
nabi receives messages from his family
in afghanistan his brother is terrified
and is pleading for help
they don't dare leave the house
they're in hiding right now
they're alone and they need help
we should give them support and help as
soon as possible
otherwise their lives will be lost their
lives are in danger right now
he tries to explain the precarious
situation to an employee from the berlin
state office for refugee affairs
they should extend this more flights to
evacuate the ones who are really at risk
and in danger
nabi is desperate and asks why more
isn't being done he feels he put his
family at risk by working for germany as
a translator
of course the german government has a
responsibility to help us
because we help them in our country
and we supported them to complete the
mission
now it's time for them to help us give
us our hope back to give us our families
back
they should evacuate our families
because our families supported us to run
the mission beside them
he's worried about his family back home
but officials here can only help him
my next guest is lucas vena he works for
an organization that supports those
afghans who assisted the german armed
forces during their mission in
afghanistan mr vayner it's good to have
you on the program you know a lot has
happened today i know you're in touch
with people who have not made it out of
afghanistan yet um have you been able to
talk with them today and what are they
telling you
good evening most of them are very
desperate right now they are
to say panicking
and um the last days it was really a
humanitarian catastrophe right at the
airport um thousands of afghans there
in the midst of them our local staff
in fact um some of our local staff
was mainly at abigaid where one of the
explosion explosions was today
and
they have been especially um now
panicking where should we go to what
should we do especially after the last
planes left
so um we're currently in the process of
trying to track everybody down in terms
of um creating new lists of the people
who were left behind
so that within the next days we are
trying to to implement our own
procedures to get these people out
the german evacuation of course has
ended what's likely to happen
to these people
now i mean i know you're trying to help
them
but is it possible
to help everyone
well
i'm not sure about everyone but at least
we'll try to to help our local staff
and um
we have been in touch with with still a
few obviously it was um
pretty difficult to reach them during
last days most of them
stayed at the airport for quite a few
days
and
their cell phones went out of power they
haven't been able to to be in touch with
us
but um currently we tried to get them
out
on land way
and
yeah that's that's the main um
thing how we help them i have about a
minute left with you uh i want to ask
you i i just spoke with mr kizzaveter he
is a member of the german parliament
he's on the foreign affairs committee he
said that the german mission in
afghanistan was a failure
what do you say to that
i wouldn't say that the entire mission
was a failure i would say
during the last days
our
government hasn't really heard hurt
listen to us what we had to say about
our local staff
we had to rent own safe houses for local
staff
and the government totally forgot about
local staff during the last years during
the last month and that was a failure
okay lucas weiner from the sponsorship
network for afghan employees mr vayner
we appreciate your time
and your insights tonight thank you
thank you